ah yes
i don't know it's all [ __ ] the
world's gone to [ __ ] dude it's fine the
queen died and that's another thing dude
here there you go tradition
so [ __ ] annoying oh there's still
queens and kings
dude
huh
hey
that's that first of all that's insane
you know what they're gonna be queens
and kings until you build cars
if you have cars which pretty much we
all do no kings and queens anymore like
if you're [ __ ] working
you know
in south africa trying to mine blood
diamonds
and you got to get everywhere with like
one jeep and a few [ __ ] lions
or whatever
or you know like what you've got like
two jeeps and then other men carry
everyone else then there can be a king
right because you need to [ __ ] make
people want to carry you
but if you've got like multiple cars and
[ __ ] and trains and airplanes
dude
no queens no kings
it's insane
it's so weird and she died and now the
[ __ ] guy with the [ __ ]
sausage fingers got to be the king
you see his hands
he looks like uh what's that [ __ ]
scene from big
little big
china what the [ __ ] big trouble in
little china when the guy blows up
he looks like he's [ __ ] five percent
into that scene
what's his name charles
prince now he's king charles it is like
70 what you know
got that guy
i'm just hoping she [ __ ] dies soon
you know with his little sausage [ __ ]
with his with his farmer john fingers i
know i just you know of course oh all
glory to the queen but it's just like
you know you know what happens when she
dies right
my sausage fingers get more rings on it
you know what happens right i got to be
the king night's fine like it's all good
and i want her to be the queen but it's
like you know what happens when she dies
all right i'll become the most important
man
and then she died and he just goes like
this all right and we [ __ ] go she
died and he was just like
his [ __ ] sausage fingers putting on
the ray-bans
putting on the aviators what happened
what but she died
what happened the queen thought
hit the wrong button [ __ ] yeah dude
um
so now he's the [ __ ] king and he's
the king and he's gonna die in like five
years dude
the lengthy she was the queen for like
900 years and he's gonna be the king for
six months
talk about the [ __ ] raw end dude
he could have just been
scooping that [ __ ] up and now he's just
like you know it doesn't work right
he's just now he's just got to [ __ ]
be like ruling
y'all so you're not doing [ __ ] at that
point when you're ruling a country and
you're [ __ ] 75.
i feel like the president actually does
real work and the king's just like
you know bring me some more lemonade
and don't allow blacks in here
apparently like she was so racist but
she had [ __ ] 45 dogs and she treated
the dogs better than the minorities or
something the queen i don't know i don't
mean to [ __ ] i have no idea this
podcast you come here for hard-hitting
news but honestly i'm going to tell you
when i don't know and i don't know
i'm the [ __ ] king of england
how about that
how about [ __ ] that
look at this [ __ ] time magazine thing
from
1973 the man who will be king and here
he is
prince charles britain's prince charles
49 years ago dude
imagine making the cover of a [ __ ]
thing this guy's gonna be king look at
him so happy he's leaning up against a
tree
49 years go by and then he's he's like
no i don't even [ __ ] want the thing
god damn it so i
don't even [ __ ] get that [ __ ]
what's important have a king being a
king and i'm going to get a fang suck
jobs it's not
so anyway rip to the queen
[Music]
crazy
crazy
[Music]